eight pork products crammed into one
huge pork patty what's up internet i'm
the sauce boss from epic meal time i'm
here with my boy chef atari today we're
gonna be baking the power pork patty but
a little toned down scaled down version
that you can make in your home in your
small ovens and we didn't stop there
we're gonna even bake and wrap that in a
bacon weave let's make it happen
so the power pork patty's special
because when you're constantly thinking
up recipes we always have to reach into
the deepest darkest corners of what
could be or should be a meal
everybody's always like oh my god i'd
love to eat an epic meal oh my god then
you put them in front of an epic meal
they don't even know what to do with it
like they don't even know their first
bite or how to even approach it and then
it's like exactly people sometimes just
get a little scared or a little shocked
at how big these larger-than-life meals
are epic meal time's always been about
innovation and i saw in the food game
there was just lots of meals that could
be taken to the next level that weren't
being taken to the next level whenever i
have a crazy idea i go up to a mirror
and i'm like let's make it happen he's
like it sounds impossible i'm like well
that's your job
and he makes it happen he makes the
impossible possible
we call ourselves google chefs we see it
we look at it and we multiply the hell
out of it so my role on epic meal time
is bacon manipulation transformation
engineer once we first started out it
was just like you know we were just
joking around and having a good time but
then there were you know leading minds
in the culinary world looking to us to
see what we were doing we have now
become the forefront of ridiculous meal
concepts being a gorilla chef cooking
unconventionally is the science there's
never ever really a right or wrong way
to cook so just go for it i've never
thought i'd be cooking an ostrich egg on
the side of arnold schwarzenegger's tank
we made the uh steak nager sandwich
steak in egger
pure pork deliciousness this is like a
personal pork patty still powerful you
got that sweetness from the ham in there
saltiness from the sausage
yeah that's a mini power pork patty
feels delicious in my power pork palate
oh yes
[Music]
you